Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller who is really, really, really
excited that Republicans are taking control
of the House in January. Listen to this guy.
Speaker 3: Republicans now control the House.
Now it's time for or payback for all those
Democrats. And smelly, smelly Pelosi.
Yes.
Speaker 1: The caller wants payback for those
Democrats and for smelly Pelosi. I hate to break
it to this caller. By the way, he doesn't actually
sound that excited. I hate to break it to this
caller, but Republicans have already made clear
what they are going to do in the two years that
they're about to control the House. Number one,
they're going to obstruct anything Democrats
try to do to help the country. They'll try to
get in the way. That's number one. And number
two, Republicans will investigate Hunter Biden.
The payback for all of the terrible things
Hunter Biden did to this country is going to come
from investigations into Hunter Biden, which
don't make any sense. He's not running for
anything. He's not in any way involved in Joe
Biden's presidency. We know what's coming. It's
going to be pathetic. It's going to be a joke
on today's bonus show. The New York City mayor
says that New York City is going to treat the
mentally ill even if they refuse treatment or
try to refuse treatment. What's going on here?
We're going to talk about what's happening in New
York City. Twitter is reportedly now having
trouble making payroll. Some employees are
reportedly not being paid on time at Twitter. What
is happening there? And number three, England and
Wales are now minority Christian countries based
on the latest census. What does the data mean?
What are the majorities and what is the future of
England and Wales as what have historically been
Christian countries? A very interesting situation.
And is the same coming to the United States. The
demographics may well be pointing in that very
same direction. All of those stories we are going
to be talking about on today's bonus show, which
you can sign up for join Pacman dot com. Also,
I want to ensure that everyone who wants it has
downloaded the free white paper on. Consider
getting people who disagree with you politically
to reconsider their views. It's called building
arguments without burning bridges. You can get the
guide for free. You know, people write to me and
they say, David, I have tears in my eyes because
I want the white paper, but I can't afford it. The
white paper is free. You also do not need to email
me for the white paper. I had people emailing me
saying, David, can you send me the white paper?
No, it's all completely automated and available
to you whenever you want it. Here are the steps.
You go to David Pakman dot com slash guide.
You type in your email address and we email
you the white paper. It's completely free.
It's completely free. It's completely free. Over
1500 people have now downloaded the white paper.
Unbelievable numbers. Get that, get the bonus
show. Get the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show. Do the entire thing. And I
will see you on the bonus show in mere moments